i i would eat toast in japan but the
bread sucks and the other place you get
good bread from is like bakeries and
they're stupidly expensive yeah yeah
it's like 50 bucks for a for a slice of
bread what what like irks me about a lot
about like the normal japanese bread
that they sell at supermarkets it's just
how [ __ ] thick it is it's ridiculous
it's like insane it's like that i'm like
it could barely fit in my [ __ ] toes
that's true i'm not gonna lie right i
know this is gonna make me sound
privileged as [ __ ] yeah i don't wanna
[ __ ] cut the bread
i wanna just chuck that [ __ ] in the
toaster i've just woken up right i don't
want to have to get the breadboard out
the bread knife out
oh it's too thick oh i've cut it badly i
just want the perfect slice this is not
a privileged thing this is just this is
absolutely a privileged thing what are
you on this is this is why they say the
best invention since sliced bread
yeah it's literally it's literally a
human revolution right don't you just
want to just do you really do do you
really slice bread really that
revolutionary
i've never thought about actually the
history of that saying it literally
takes 10 seconds dude but it's not it's
not the act of cutting it it's the
cleaning up i have to clean up a [ __ ]
breadboard a bread knife now just for
like one slice of bread like if i just
have if i just have the sliced bread i
chucked that [ __ ] out what about if you
just buy the loaf of bread for example
the uncut loaf of bread on that day you
slice it up preemptively you put it back
in the bag and now you've got something
like that you've created that i did that
no that's [ __ ] up i mean i can't
really really like speed run it going
bad no
yeah i don't think i've ever bought
bread that's not been pre-sliced now
that i think about it in my life at
least wow privilege right now
just showing you call me privilege for
slashing my bread at least i've done the
leg work i've been there i've been in
the trenches sliced my own bread
i've lived that life i've lived a lot on
that now
like aside from like you know [ __ ]
baguettes or whatever yeah i've never
actually sliced my own like wow loaf of
bread
yeah call me privilege call me favorites
upper classes right here this is like
the the like the opposite of like you
know people from england have never
cooked like their own rice or something
you know me an asian i've never sliced
my own bread before
there is a bakery near me that i really
like yeah
the loaf of bread is uh
six bucks i think how being half half a
standard size yeah yeah okay half a
standard size i'm sure it's great i'm
sure it's great i just don't want to pay
six bucks for half half my life i've had
yeah because like mine i have to cut it
oh [ __ ] right oh [ __ ] me yeah like for
six bucks i'm not [ __ ] cutting that
yeah that's ridiculous i mean
i thought that as well but then at my
previous place we lived right next to
like this like really high-end bakery
and like a full loaf like like this big
was like nine bucks or something which
is like [ __ ] still still expensive
but then and i thought it was just like
a scam being like oh jack just this is
just japan
yeah this is just japanese people not
knowing goodbye but then when i bought
it and i had it and you know i had to
slice it myself god forbid i had to
slice it myself and uh yeah i made toast
with and i'm like okay
i can see why this is nine bucks no no
it was amazing it was very good but it
was not no no i wouldn't pay nine bucks
for that outside of japan is what i'm
saying why why would you pay for inside
japan because every other [ __ ] brand
of japan sucks
i guess and it's like look don't get me
wrong i'm not [ __ ] buying this every
day for me this is like this loaf of
bread i would this nine dollar life of
bread i would buy was like maybe like
once every like couple of months how
good was that like in terms of
bread in general this line this nine
dollar bread compared to like
it was [ __ ] good like it was better
than like any like supermarket bread i
would buy in like australia or like
anywhere outside of japan so it was like
i've had the same bread because i bought
it it was it was good it was really
really good like i was like okay this
actually
tastes like this is
how does it compare to like say the
bread in europe you know i think the
bread that i had in france in germany
was better well yeah oh no obviously
i'm asking how much better was it than
this top bread top-tier nine dollar
bread that we have brought in like
marginally it got to that taste where it
was good like it was very good yeah
right but then that the one in germany
or france will cost like
one euro fifty yeah yeah
right if you're having rice in europe
then obviously the one in japan is going
to taste better just because you know in
the uk it was like what a pound for
warburtons is it warburton's the toast
bread i love that toast
it is very good bread
although i would not and even in the uk
right when you buy animals when you buy
the loaf bread at the supermarket the
one that isn't cut yeah you can be like
can you can you can you cut it for me
you can buy uncut bread at the
supermarket yeah
we have baker we have bakeries and you
know we have bakeries in the supermarket
do you know what a bakery is there's a
bakery right and then when you get your
your pastries wherever they all sell
loafs of bread yeah i actually get
pastries i've never seen a loaf of bread
yeah they have it and if you want the
loaf of bread uncut you can who does
that who asks for that a lot of people
do because a lot of people like you know
if they're making their own stuff then
it's not not a big deal that they're
cutting because they want it because the
moment you cut it the time is ticking
it's already going bad right yeah that's
why you don't want to cut the whole
bread then put it back in because then
those slices that might have tasted a
bit fresher two three days are gonna be
rock solid did you never put like your
bread in the freezer
what no because that's the way to make
bread long-lasting that's what we used
to in australia i'm sure
[Music]
last longer that's like putting ice in
beer you know like like that's the the
the [ __ ] you just don't do and like you
gotta understand like the loaf of bread
in the uk and in europe it's bought on
the day intended to all be used on that
day oh okay that's not supposed to be
obviously you can have it a day that's
not a big deal but but we don't you
don't freeze the bread
because they're strange because the
australian loves the bread there's like
20 [ __ ] slices right so even a family
can't go through it in like a day how
big is this bread like this let's just
buy a smaller like a loaf of bread like
this yeah it's like it's like regular
like this big or like 20 slices in it so
obviously
slice yeah does it taste as good i want
an image of this
exactly
i don't believe that it's like the big
foot of bread this can't be real yeah so
like you know just to make the bread
last a little bit longer because you
don't want to have [ __ ] loads of
bread every day right especially if
you're living in like my household which
was kind of half rice half bread
right um
like this yeah i'm not even the bread
guys like the size of the uk one but
yeah but they're weight but they're way
thinner
yeah but like anyway so like yeah to
make the bread last longer uh we'd put
you know we would use the slices we
needed to use on the day we buy it and
then we immediately go into the freezer
because it'll last like an extra two
three weeks and then you just and if you
wanted if you want a slice of bread you
grab it you know obviously it's frozen
because it's been in the freezer you
throw it into the toaster
instantly defrosted taste i'm not even
the bread guy and i would never put
myself down to such savagery as fast as
pudding as putting uh bread in the
freezer i'm sorry you higher privileged
people could buy bread whenever you
wanted my family was saving money all
right
your family had a financial advisor joey
what are you talking about
and that financial advisor was like
freeze your brand you got to change some
things around here you want it you want
that do you want that new apartment you
better freeze your goddamn bread boy
it's the asian mentality yeah yeah we
put everything to put everything in the
freezer last longer save money yeah
exactly no i think this is [ __ ] this
is just your excuses for living like
savages yeah we're australian yeah
if it was something like oh we don't
want the spiders to get it okay well
that too no no because you would even
get a bread bin yeah no because the
bread bin would be [ __ ] annihilated
by the ants what yeah
because we're in australia you can't
escape from the wildlife
yeah you leave the door open for one
second too long your house is [ __ ]
overridden by ants
the one thing that makes me not proud uh
to be thai is one thing that they do and
i just said it they they put ice in
their beer that's disgusting and like
it's
i mean i i see the logic because
obviously it's like 30 35 degree weather
beer is gonna get warm uh beer's gonna
get warm a lot faster but even me even
me i'm just like no no ice my bear
please no we're not we're not we're not
gonna go is that like an option you can
get at any restaurant
um they normally or is that like a
backyard thing no no no by default okay
by default in thailand in a lot of like
restaurants
especially if it's open air right um you
order a beer they uh they take a cartel
they say they give you the beer and they
give you a glass and they put ice in it
and then they pour the beer in the glass
full of ice and you have to specifically
ask in a lot of places for them not to
do that right um just trying to hide the
[ __ ]
yeah is there anything worse than
watered down thai beer
what a nightmare i mean i mean you see
that you do that with a chang beer and
it's just like this beer was already
watered down and uh you're watering it
down even more flavored water
sorry sorry germans watching this yeah
the germans had a heart attack listening
to that like
but i've never i've never put bread in
the freezer i'll say that i'll say that
we've never put bread in the freezer hey
man
i'm not doing that i'm not saying you
should i was just saying that's what we
did and uh i know i thought it was
normal is it is it like do you have to
put like eggs in the fridge
yeah
i can't i can't i can't remember where i
heard it from where like if you have to
put like some things in the fridge or
some things are fine because it depends
on the country and how it's cleaned
right i believe in some places in europe
uh they recommend you not to fridge the
eggs can you google this
if i'm recalled correctly i think we
didn't keep our eggs in the fridge yes
growing up yeah don't think we did i
don't think we did either in japan
you're supposed to keep the
eggs in the fridge or i don't think yeah
you have to oh yeah you have to keep it
in the fridge european countries say you
do not yeah that's right that's right
really that's right i don't we had it in
a cupboard
really yeah well that's weird and in
america i think they put it in the
fridge i don't know about japan i don't
know as someone who was just born of
like
just kind of you know every time i went
shopping with my mom and we'd buy a [ __ ]
the moment we should like open the front
door she'd be like eggs in the fridge
now quickly they're gonna go bad
apparently it's illegal to wash eggs in
europe so yeah like i've got like the
stuff illegal so you're doing the fridge
it's actually gonna grow back to you
what the egg police are gonna [ __ ]
rock up to my door be like um
i think it means for like transporting
it and stuff
yeah we don't yeah we killed them in the
cupboard i remember that yeah yeah like
bread you've never put in the fridge
eggs we've never put in the fridge
potatoes i don't think we've got
potatoes were in the pantry yeah yeah
yeah
because i think if you put in the fridge
it grows sprouts right i don't know or
something like that i don't know i know
i know potatoes you're not supposed to
spawn in the fridge and onions yeah i
think because i feel like rue is
different with every different country i
go to because in thailand it's just like
90 percent of everything goes in the
fridge yeah because it's so much [ __ ]
hotter there yeah
it's hot it goes yeah yeah hot and humid
is like not the best in
best
and conditions for bacteria right so
yeah yeah exactly well like other things
you shouldn't like like chocolate you're
not supposed to put in the fridge i know
i like putting chocolate in the fridge
wait why do you
why i think it's because like if you put
chocolate in the fridge then it turns
white and that just means that like it's
gone bad what i've never seen like
chocolate in the fridge this sounds like
some [ __ ] i i love my chocolate
yeah white stuff is not that the
chocolate it's just some others
what what is that some other stuff i'm
worried
i don't know like i i i always heard
this yeah i always heard you shouldn't
put chocolate in the fridge for too long
or like you could you can't let it like
sit in the fridge i don't know maybe
that's just me
it's either sugar or fat but it's not
the chocolate oh yeah okay yeah i
definitely prefer my chocolate in the
fridge okay there's there's two like
states of chocolate that are like my
favorite one is just like in the fridge
it's hard you get a nice nice crunchy
bite out of it and the second stage
where it's like like cheaper chocolate
it's like when it's perfectly room
temperature but not melted
if you if like when you put in your
mouth it easily melts yeah yeah you put
it in your mouth and it doesn't like it
doesn't melt but it just like dissolves
in your mouth right that's like that's
like my second favorite
snaps apart and breaks into nice
chocolate bites i like that i don't like
it i don't like that too much because
i've had some instances where i'm like
what's going to break first the
chocolate or my teeth
i don't want to find yeah there are some
chocolates are like way too hard for
that yeah there are some like the
caramel bars i've never put in the
fridge oh my god
if you put hard caramel in the fridge
like goodbye
it's just literally jawbreaking you're
just eating rocks at that point yeah
yeah what about ice cream do you like do
you like your ice cream like hard or
like soft served do you like biting into
your eyes heart yeah like lollies like
like do you do you like i saw an ice
cream there okay yeah that's i i i guess
that's an ice block your ice cream hard
or soft
well you've had like feasts right where
it's like it's like an ice cream one
you know fees where it's like like a
chocolate in the middle and it's like an
ice cream around it oh you mean like uh
that's more of a
that's not so much ice cream though it's
more like a ice cream bar i'd say like
it's more of a it's got like a layer
around